les premiers pas les premiers sourires
les premiers mots des moments précieux
avec sa fille Ariane née que ça vous
Sarah o Niango car la vie d'un enfant
elle le sait est fragile
[Musique]
à la clinique éveil à ce que sa fille et
tous les vaccins disponibles et s'il est
une chose qu'elle craint par dessus tout
c'est le paludisme aussi appelé malaria
selon l'OMS la maladie tue plus de 600
000 personnes chaque année en très
grande majorité des enfants africains de
moins de 5 ans une vie fauchée toutes
les deux minutes
heureusement un nouveau vaccin contre la
malaria vient d'être approuvé par
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
dans cette clinique il est maintenant
prescrit à tous les nourrissons
appelé RTSS ou mosquée Rix est un
développement majeur dans la lutte
contre la malaria l'aboutissement de 30
ans d'efforts de la part de chercheurs
comme le professeur Simon keryuki
le professeur car Yuki a consacré sa vie
à la lutte contre le paludisme mais le
développement du vaccin n'a pas été
simple
vous prenez walking
la recherche contre la malaria allantant
souffert de manque de financement
malheureusement
le parasite qui cause la maladie
transmis par des piqûres de moustiques
s'est révélée un adversaire redoutable
le vaccin mosquérix offre une efficacité
d'environ 40% contre la malaria mais ce
n'est là que début
d'autres vaccins comme le R21
actuellement testé s'annonce beaucoup
plus efficace et un traitement basé sur
des anticorps monoclonaux semblent lui
aussi très prometteur des pas de géant
franchis au cours des dernières années
qui permettent enfin d'être optimiste
Sarah va continuer à drainer l'eau
stagnante sur son terrain à utiliser des
insecticides et surtout à dormir sous
une moustiquaire meilleur moyen de
protéger celle qu'elle surnomme sa
petite reine
[Musique]